estamos en malaya arrojan por dos meses
las tropas rusas ocuparon y atacaron
este pueblo del sur de jarquín en su
asedio a esta importante ciudad la
población local incluso vio los
barracones donde se resguardaban hasta
que el ejército ucraniano retomó el
control de la aldea
una talla pasó semanas en este sótano
mientras las tropas rusas se encontraban
en el pueblo
y de monitor si salíamos a buscar ayuda
humanitaria corríamos el riesgo de que
nos matarán podía ver a los
francotiradores desde la entrada de la
puerta de mi casa tres hombres fueron
asesinados así un hombre caminaba con su
hijo de cuatro años y también lo mataron
helicópteros abatidos hospitales
acribillados automóviles incendiados es
el paisaje de esta aldea los restos de
los combates se ven en todas partes no
queda prácticamente nadie en este pueblo
sólo las personas que resistieron a la
ocupación rusa y la artillería sigue
retumbando en roban otra aldea cercana
badín poljak tiembla al hablar del
desamparo que sintió
no entiendo aquí no hay objetivos
militares solo muchas casas en las que
viven personas no entiendo nuestra gente
vivía en paz de u2 de valentina es otra
superviviente nos muestra el salón de su
casa no queda nada intacto
todavía estamos en shock y tenemos miedo
cuando oímos un ruido nos escondemos
enseguida captan la guerra aún está
cerca de estas aldeas el ejército
ucraniano y ruso batallan por pocos
metros de tierra en un conflicto de
desgaste de final incierto